hello and welcome to this video it's
been a while since I recorded one and um
yeah this of course a reason for for
doing videos again and I think everyone
agrees that there are simply more time
to be spend at home currently this is
also why this is called stay at home and
enjoy HS going to play a couple of games
and um hope that you are entertained and
maybe educated in some moments so let's
see what we got here got c4 plating and
against me by monster farm okay I'm
going to play a classical way oh okay
III is not very aggressive on the first
whose looks a vegetable but of course
white is developing very sensibly and
I'll be bad um I also adjusted the
layout a little bit prepare to earlier
sessions um I hope it is it looks fine
I wanted to have a layout that is also
suitable for later analysis um I hope
this is going to do the job
kind of expected that he played very
yeah unambitious Lee Saudi takes e5 is
kind of I am NOT a surprise
caps on c5 is usually not such a bad
choice sometimes white actually has a
little bit of a pull in those positions
but you take on c5 usually not with the
pawn being on a4 already because that
makes your or queen side as wide look a
little bit ridiculous so it's it's a bit
odd that you took at this particular
point but of course I'm yeah white is
still in a fairly solid Ashe and we see
that it is largely symmetrical
the main thing you have to do in in such
a position of you of course if you want
to play ambitiously and want to win the
game you have to be yeah somewhat
ancient you're not going to
yeah when quickly in any any soda way
and our white is taking a bit of time I
would expect well that's surprising
he puts it on deform I can it's possible
now to take this night and go for an IQ
p position
[Music]
you
I wonder if it is an idea to take with
the
and angle 97 and Bishop c6 we can still
play d5 yeah okay it's it's it's tough
if you look for a long time and try to
find something great you might as well
end up in time trouble this is a three
plus two
okay sting
okay I'm winning a tempo here with the
rookie the only thing that I don't like
so much about this Saturday I have lots
of black - in real estate still but it
kind of wow really okay
and I find kind of surprising that he is
so willingly damaging his own pawn
structure on the kingside
looks like a very weak pawn structure in
every single pawn is weak
so I'm lining up against the pawn here
so um there's a lot of black screen area
and I'm not so sure that it's best but
as you will see in the analysis view you
need some of it on the right hand side
and I mean I think the most important
thing is that you see the clock times
and you definitely do in the setup
and I mean the webcam I don't know I
don't think you need to have it
it cannot be much bigger really
yes well I will see maybe as some room
for optimization there but it's not the
most important thing
okay now I'm I'm on my way with the
night to go to f5 or b-52 per them
increase the pressure on the d4 pawn and
five could be interesting because
there's also the opportunity here to
jump to age four but I like b5 even more
because it's a very stable square and
I'm also stopping his rook there from
attacking the the pawn on b7 I could
have already won a pawn with Knight
takes c3 in this position but I don't
want you this is some I think surely you
can still or not Queen d7 place okay you
can still improve this position quite a
bit
now
to d7
I wonder if the knight on c6 is actually
and to stop that it would be really
great on f5 now also checking age for
his continuing to weaken is positioning
more so not going to
anything here now 93 maybe coming
you
YUM no night if five
to trade that I mean this is not bad
which can never really be bad
now back and now I see what I should do
I should actually now bring the other
night to f5
this is going to be nice
yeah I can always win upon in 93r okay
five but I don't want the F icon I want
the h4 pawn the not coming to f5 will
win this pawn
okay you can go Bishop II one and go all
the way
I serve but
this is very beautiful everything is on
light squares this is how it should be
in such a situation
very very harmonious setup so I don't
mind to trade Iruka
know that I have already won upon
continue this only
get the route to b5
we can step-by-step win/win Quantium
or could be 595 org and five this also
really
let me think about it the moment
oh this is good
I wanted to I was thinking about
activating the king going to d7 but I
wanted to do it without allowing we
should be formed so that he can get rid
of his bishop
so the king activated and now
[Music]
can win another pond maybe the F for
porn or are we just going to push this
yeah why not actually I can just push
the pond do this
also quite convincing
[Music]
you
when de-spawn or
yeah
this is almost a maid f6 hook age for
maids f6 he has to
[Music]
can we not somehow made him to end this
game I don't see it well okay it's not a
problem I mean then we just trade him
for the for the winning ending
um but how do we actually win what is
the most convincing way to do it
Bishop is coming to c3 so maybe block it
let's go here nice to go back on yeah be
everything
you
okay so now if we go to the nether this
board you see why I did
structure right hand side the way I did
so now you can see the move list and you
can see the evaluation on top as it is
usually requested I don't think we need
we need
and yes
they change the
with that anyway I think we need to look
at a couple of moments here briefly I
think this position is still equal I
think the computer agrees yeah if white
is doing something normal here let's say
I don't know look see one I expected him
to play something like that it's just
about equal I'm happy with black because
I have I think smile a small symbolic
advantage due to a for being this is a
bit weaker who wider than for black here
the queenside but it's not enough but
you have anything substantial
he played 94 which is a surprise that
gives me a little bit of hope and now
you have this option both captures look
good I did not go for this because I
thought I saw this but I thought like
here he would go d5 and simply get rid
of his pawn easily but the engine claims
that he 5 is good
which could be true am absolutely it's
definitely an option okay so I went with
sorry I went with the other capture in
97 and of course again he can play d5
but I thought that this could still be a
little something because I thought that
I will take everything
what's my my fraud and then I go here
and if he takes I'm still looking at
this well it still I can just do this
yeah that's true
I have no way to enter yeah okay it's
equal he should go d5 then simply event
85 ship c6 now to stop them to stop the
pawn advancing and now he played the
absolutely terrible Bishop f3 this is
just
yeah that's really really a terrible
move your your merely lost I guess no
just it is too bad and I have multiple
ways of being better Knight f5 could
even be stronger as the engine suggests
but this is a this position is just
strategically completely lost
Jim I think what I did was fine there
there might have been quicker ways but
you can simply one by one
I'm attack all the weaknesses and and
Windham there's just nothing else to say
about this you should absolutely never
play Bishop f3
if you play something let's say f3
that's what I expected something like
that
I meant Bishop f2 this is the idea I
would rather be black and the engine
gives me a small edge but it's nothing
special
yeah you can still defend this position
ok now let's go form a new game just
click on 3 + 2 and see what happens
it's my intention to do those videos
regularly ideally on a daily basis and
they should be roughly half an hour
maybe a little bit more depending on how
things unfold
like government
going to like Rhonda
they're just like roughly roughly 30
minutes I think this is a good
good form
all right so this is something that I
looked at of course in my keep it simply
D for which you can see behind me not
not quite not quite now 95 this line is
featured in my book I think it's a very
good practical choice many black players
don't know that Bishop d7 is the best
movie 'im and they play this or even
take on d4 and this is a very good for
white okay but all nice and good but you
have to know why
I think it's night a3 remember correctly
yeah this is possible but I think I'm
white has very good compensation here if
I'm remembering this correctly
it's it's absolutely right for him to
grab the pawn now he should do that have
at least some something for his misery
let's say the problem here says I'm just
threatening e4 and if my memory serves
me correctly you have to really snatch
this pawn it's not very elegant you give
up the bishop on g2 but it's a matter of
it's a matter of time we want to we want
to catch like with the king in the
middle if possible mmm interesting move
Bishop c6 this is intention
came
so um something like
you
hmm it's something where I would really
love to have more time
planers I would also like to play Bishop
g5 so that Bishop e7 is not such an easy
move to play
you
yeah I don't I have to make a move now
it's just like yeah I would totally like
to have more time
it would be extremely helpful such a
position
for example a move like if or here could
be quite interesting but I don't have
time to check it out
okay so let's do this we need three
edges player three this is not a problem
and now I can take on c5 so he returns
the pawn
question is is it the best one let's
move to blame ma'am I have to do it just
for practical purposes
so let's go F Reem
stop the maid
I definitely had something better than
this
but I couldn't find it with the time
constraints
so stepping out of the discovered attack
not really sure what disposition should
be evaluated
how this position should be evaluated am
i Murcia or is it okay probably okay I
would assume
I'm a little bit concerned about c2 here
like he could
he could maybe
Bishop to b5 or something I'm clay what
you do it's not going to not going to
happen he wants to check this oh you're
doing it okay I'm just doubling
yeah
covering Siwon
the bishop
okay
hm can we do something something
ambitious here is it possible a move
like g4 for example could be interesting
aren't you cut away the Queen a little
bit
and away cut off here cutaway is weird
okay so he's out for this I have to stop
it
maybe a queen deform could be added an
idea Queen D for intending to pushy six
23 seconds is a bit of a problem
you
I didn't see at all that's was hanging
you
still not very concerned honestly
you
into f4 could be
problem
you know this one
that's very unfortunate
you
I was a bit of a silly game it was
really difficult to lose it but I
managed
what the heck
you
very difficult to lose it
you
very silly plane really
you
I camp like we need to even
Bishop's are nice but she's got so many
points
you
when he ponds and now he manages to
trade yes I came and I was super silly
yeah you should never lose this game I
mean the moment he we were here only
white can be bad egg I'm totally winning
actually which which is even more
frustrating yeah because he's not really
threatening anything Bishop c3 is not
necessary is just a check he six is
winning everything basically wins
probably because of queen d-46 being
completely devastating but probably this
is also winning I mean it's pretty clear
that I should have a large advantage
here but I totally screwed it up
honestly I just didn't see Queen edge
form this is what's the problem
mr. normal move is good
much better centralized and I mean I'm a
porn up disposition still
[Music]
probably this is also just winning
somehow
oh six f6f four wins
the thing I really it just tough to lose
it I just didn't see Bishop b5 I mean
just just like a huge one move blunder
quindi aid
when the end I mean we probably just win
if it wasn't for Bishop b5
you should be five wins for black yeah
not a good game my meme so let's go for
one more
hopefully playing a bit better
[Music]
it's always frustrating if you get I
should have checked the opening actually
because I didn't get as much as I should
have
they take c5 this line is really bad
came upon gue 67 is going for the 3d
form is much more challenging but it's
not so commonly played at least if
you're playing
our non professional players
often times white places slowish setup
and this basically gives black the best
ruler pass ever that you can imagine
[Music]
yeah I mean he black is just very fine
[Music]
have owned space advantage in the center
already a couple of options here I can
simply wait one
I don't think f5 is on the agenda
Kim
it's got the dd4 idea I could have
played the 5-1 move earlier and I
probably should have done that because
him
it's really tough to prevent deform
you
of great
you
okay I did not want to do that but it's
just like I know you play that like in
instant
okay maybe he
you get it all out while I was thinking
possible
but still
I mean it's giving up the default porn
and all kinds of things but
see what happens
you
yeah so he wants to get this to f3 I
guess
okay Michael Knight c6 Knight f3 Bishop
g7
yeah that looks correct
your next move will be important
maybe
you should go if I've simply
yeah oh this one that was the other move
okay
you
yeah what's right here it's a good
question
like to play 95 quickly on that deform
[Music]
it's not so it's not so yeah I should do
that
[Music]
maybe this one
you
I've I can probably take with the pawn
okay and this is interesting because I
have a couple of technical options now I
can go 94 for example and then take on
c2
my bishop is quite clearly hanging so
something
to be aware of but could be other
options as well
[Music]
and a five makes no sense to me
you
I would like a better solution than
straining stuff
but maybe that's what I have to do so
let's do this queen bee seven
really there's a thought
Oh a scare today that I'm that I
overlooked something silly I wanted to
go night deform and Knight takes bishop
shakes but this is of course illegal
that's unfortunate
I still like to do that so maybe I can
swayed him by giving up the pawn
yeah man my time is just seriously down
[Music]
my dears Queen h4 doesn't react to it at
all okay
and ev3 coming
it's got to check on a seven that's the
only
scary thing that I see at first glance
g3 Queen g3 this is the thing
and I'm threatening Queen g3 here so big
threat
you
okay
[Music]
this is not bad but is it best as the
thing I don't know
is it best I don't know but it's very
good for black probably winning
when h1 May
some he more or less has to take g2
you
you
don't have much time so
I better be quick
oh that's made I was I was happy that
there was a maid so who is just a couple
of seconds it's better yeah I'm not so
happy with this game I think I did not
really make the best of my chances
so him um when we go here I played this
a bit too routinely yeah King h7 I
should think about d5 immediately
because currently there's no bishop only
three so this is not hanging so I get to
play d5 and I mean yeah look at this I
have a these pawns here give me a pretty
substantial space advantage and I think
I mean the computer gives me a slight
edge which is probably fair looks good
good send them
I played the very routine King age seven
and after Bishop III it's not so easy to
play d5 I mean it happens at the
computer likes f5 but yeah so this is
not a mistake then but I would have
liked the clean look of d5 the move
performed and he played d4 instantly
which is probably a big mistake
yeah that's a big mistake um and the
engine also gives this alternative which
which I thought but I thought what I was
doing was better he had this in d5 I saw
that but I thought I I made the better
choice in with the computer loves this
yeah many it looks very good yeah I've
got this if the knight moves and de
force basically basically toast now
that's it's probably stronger even yeah
I like this but
it's not a big difference actually
but somewhere here I can probably
improve 95 that's not really a very
intuitive move to me
95 ok
I mean it's clear that this is fantastic
right I have a really great extra pawn
much more space and so on but he can
take here and this is seems to be
completely lost
yeah the move Queen g5 is probably such
a problem or any other attacking I am
that's true like here I can Pro I can
take here right here special h3 because
that is winning
threatening to attack with everything
that I have okay so 95 was very strong I
played the routine move Bishop g7 and
Jim okay this is strong rook a seven I
have because he cannot take the Queen
strapped
and this is nice because now if he goes
look t1 I can probably go here right
yeah yeah this is very nice I'm covering
this and if he takes it the Queen is
again trapped this is a fantastic idea
okay seven which I didn't find I had to
make a decision I didn't have much time
so I played I actually had time okay I
didn't find it
rook t1 and this is better for black but
not not as great as it as it was
before
oh yeah engine things there should be a
sacrifice I do understand that that's
true because he gets this back
immediately
King g8 observing of their g8
then maybe context of Bishop b2 yeah
this looks actually very dangerous for
black the computer says equal but that
looks dangerous
they should have done that yeah I'm
probably winning right f3 and I missed
win somewhere here ok I can take him
it's even stronger because this is
hanging I see okay no I didn't I didn't
see that at all that he for was hanging
with the check okay I think what I did
also should win honestly oh it doesn't
at all
Wow
fg2 though yeah I always miss that I
have this this thing
and he can actually hold with queen a7
check and then room shakes
ah I see se
cause now this is actually hanging hmm
that's bad
okay so the way it happens
I was winning and then actually with the
mate I didn't have any problems there at
the time okay so I'm I'm on 36 minutes I
think one more game is in order for the
first video let's do it
you
let's do it
you
I've got the spectator spot more than
100 people watching always nice and Alex
Cosby so this is probably one of the
higher rated games at the moment I'm
going to play my old line here from the
you
from my limbs Oh bogel book
did I do this right no not really right
No
I was seriously flawed
96 is just just odd
okay
[Music]
you
you
yeah the problem is here yes a three and
then I have to take which is of course
very desirable for Wyatt
hmm very unfortunate
[Music]
yeah this is a pretty good structure for
white
is preparing me for ins probably will
manage to play it
sometimes you can go v6 and Bishop e6 if
the light is still back on b8 but it
isn't
which makes a whole thing even more
problematic
you
Jim I can't go away five super slow
[Music]
really know what else to do yes getting
the book - E - this is all super
standard I have played this kind of
thing myself bid
still having a bit of pressure against
d4 so if he plays Evo I always has to
worry about the d4 pawn hanging rook a7
has this idea to make it more difficult
for him to push the e4 pawn so that I
can take on e4 take on d4
trying to play prophylactically against
you for push
he reinforces it
sometimes you can play h5h for in such a
situation
[Music]
you
I don't know
you
okay
not sure if I'm really preventing you
for I don't think I do
aha okay
that good okay I'm just sending it back
Knight f5 I can go g6 Knight age 490
what really
see sacrificing there or what is he
doing
this may be
okay
it's got no square yeah this is
completely unclear though it's not i'm
blundering c6 oh my goodness this is
what I overlooked
they were silly really silly
a position well actually not that bad at
this moment
I don't think it was bad really
no I was very silly stuff
you
I really thought the worst was already
over
you
yeah I can only hope for some kind of
miracle here
you
and it's not going to happen the rukon
g4 is basically killing off all my ain't
hopes
yeah he's got rookie aid even
you
ah
yeah
I would like to resign
in every Christensen's principle you
never resign as long as you have a night
some truth to that that you shouldn't do
it okay this is not changing all that
much you know
you
you know not threatening anything really
I don't think he's somehow doing it in
the most forceful way but it's it's
totally enough
you
now the bishop on g5 is compass
defending very very well
often you have Knights doing great
offensive jobs with the special boosters
right now that was super silly actually
I felt like I was doing okay for the
first time in this game when when it was
here now black is better already
and what
I completely did not see that c6 was
hanging so this is actually okay I just
have to insert c4 it seems a form
and then just play the position okay
whether this is difficult to do just
play the position if I'm not I mean I
didn't see that c6 was hanging so if I'm
here and I'm not seeing this I should
play something else maybe eight or
something I don't know before Queen f5
when f5 looks weird because the dad's
kind of a useful move anyway we
it's gets a position I mean it's
complicated I simply assembly blunder to
see six the thing I thought he has to do
this and I'm I'm okay here because I
mean he's got a couple of points but
what doesn't matter really because I get
this and again in tech but he six angst
it so there was there was a problem also
I got myself into trouble by playing an
imprecise move or that I should go d5 in
this position and after cakes you take
him and get this I played this a bit too
quickly him it's a bit of a problem
really
because you don't want this structure
it's generally believed to be better for
white anyway and yeah the thing is that
I have the knight on c6 already with the
knight being here again you sometimes
can go b6 bishop a6 there's his famous
game but Vinick kappa blanka but kappa
blanka had the same thing and kind of
Lanka was actually okay for quite a
while until he made a couple of mistakes
um but still this is some not super
comfortable for black um the way it
turned out it was okay I think what I
play was not too bad I got rid of this
and then yeah this maneuver is probably
not a bad idea yeah
Queen B 5
yeah this is the problem right you
should switch to the queenside once I
have weakened it but he was completely
focused on a central expansion now I was
doing okay but I completely blundered c6
okay I hope you enjoyed this first
session of hopefully some to come but
hopefully is actually the wrong word I
mean I hope that um the current crisis
situation gets resolved and we can
actually spend time outside a little bit
more and not stay at home all that much
thanks for watching and I'll be back
tomorrow I guess
bye bye
you